uh is long overdue for playing a
superhero and i think he's got right
he's got an actual feral nest and he's
never really gotten the role that's
gotten to show that off but every time i
see him in something i'm like this guy's
right there like i see this this edge of
this interesting choice
how's it going there reject nation john
humphrey and koi gendro here for another
exciting installment of our newest
segment koi's comic corner now before i
hand the mic off if you want to get a
couple housekeeping things out the way
if you could first leave a like and
subscribe hit that notification bell
that stuff helps us out a lot here and
you're going to want to be notified for
when the next episode drops because this
man has a wealth of knowledge and
theories and uh today we're gonna be
talking about wolverine and how he could
potentially be introduced to the mcu
moving forward without further ado i'm
gonna turn the mic over to koi koi what
do you got for us all right so i think
wolverine should come into the mcu soon
which is not a thing i originally
thought but i think he should come into
the mcu via a tv show so i'm gonna dive
into where the x-men and wolverine are
now i'm gonna dive into how i would
personally introduce wolverine how i
think they might actually be introducing
wolverine who might play him what the
plot of my series not movie would be and
some reading recommendations for you
folks awesome you see the series you say
i got okay so okay that's the biggest
jump right there let's dive in with the
shyamalan twist i originally didn't want
wolverine in the mcu for a little while
because
i know i said it out loud because i
think the biggest issue is that it
becomes wolverine in the x-men all too
quickly just like the cartoon wolverine
and the x-men just like some x-men
comics it's a team and cyclops and storm
are the leaders somehow wolverine
because he's so cool becomes the
impromptu and default focal point of the
movies brian singer did it the shows
have done at the comics have done it
what i would do is wait a minute you
mean that's not how it always is know
the thing about x-men is he wasn't even
introduced until 94 issues into the
x-men we didn't have wolverine for
decades of x-men comics and frankly i
think that's a big issue with the comic
books actually it's about a decade about
12 years anyway the issue is once you
have a character that's that cool you
lose the team dynamic so what i would do
is have a series that takes place in
canon in the mcu over the course of
decades and eventually just like an
avengers level meetup you're waiting for
wolverine to meet the x-men because you
know it's coming but that way you've got
your x-men getting their time in the sun
you've established cyclops as a leader
you establish sorem as the leader i
would do the blue and gold teams allah
jim lee's 90s x-men you established two
sets of teams that way real quick yes
this is why i'm here koi you got to make
sure that it makes sense let's clarify
for the people the blue and gold team
okay so yeah in the x-men in the 90s
when there was a giant pop of x-men
popularity they split the teams into two
one led by storm one led by cyclops and
that's actually a kind of loose basis of
the very popular x-men animated series
which is continuing on disney plus from
the original canon and that is not to me
a coincidence of where they'll be basing
a lot of the movies and shows off of i
think that being canon and living on
disney plus is going to be very
indicative and inform a lot of these
x-men choices so i think pulling from
the jim lee stuff gives you a lot of
opportunity and i think with that you
not only give wolverine his classic
brown and yellow costume but you set the
first series decades ago and i would do
each season as a different decade of
wolverine lore so you got the best of
x-men origins wolverine that opening
title sequence even if you hate that
movie which is understandable that
opening title sequence was gold make
that the show not only does that give
you opportunity to grow out the mcu not
only does that give you opportunity to
have them meet howard stark captain
america bucky barnes deadpool from back
in the you've got so many opportunities
you can really make that show its own
thing and then you've got this awesome
ticking clock of getting up to the
present day and having him meet the
x-men and then when he does it feels
like a civil war moment it feels like an
avengers infinity war because the
character you've wanted in the x-men in
x-men 3 finally gets there and then
cyclops is the leader there is a
conflict between jean grey cyclops and
wolverine and then storm is well enough
established so she doesn't say lines
about toads you've got all of these
characters no we need we need the
timelines we need the memes frankly
they're coming but i i think wolverine
is a long-form character and then this
way you also have the samurai saga you
also have his adventures in the wars and
why he's so traumatized you get to
actually live with the weapon x program
you get to see the horrors of why
wolverine is the way he is and it's not
shoehorned into flashbacks during a
movie where you've got 10 other mutants
and it's also an opportunity to have you
care about the man that is wolverine
that way when he does atrocious things
you're invested in the character as well
as the cool wolverine character with
blade hands like you gotta you gotta
love the man and it's gonna be hard to
replace you jackman so the way you do
that is you go long form you fully
invest in the meat of the character not
just the schnitt of the character i like
it coy and so okay riddle me this then
you don't want to introduce him too fast
into the x-men and have him take focus
where are the x-men during all of this
in your mcu so what i would do is
announce a wolverine show before maybe
even announcing an x-men movie i would
say hey we're gonna have this wolverine
show and that way all of the giant x-men
fans get a taste because i think they
should wait and introduce the x-men uh
probably like four or five years to be
honest i'd wait okay i'd wait a little
bit because i think fantastic four needs
to come first and i think since they
haven't utilized the x gene idea from
eternals yet they haven't utilized the
thanos snap idea all the fan theories
they haven't really activated those
seeds yet i'd give a little bit of time
i'd let some of this phase four settle
i'd let a lot of people that think phase
four is motionless which i disagree with
i think it has a very clear direction
that we're going to get after quantum
mania i would even perhaps utilize kang
to bring about the time trial of
elements that maybe you meet wolverine
in the past maybe when you bring kang in
you've got 1940 set wolverine and that
ties into the show using time travel in
the movies establish a james howlett
establish a character that we as comic
fans might recognize give us the
subtlest little boop i know who that is
or a post-credit scene you can even go
obvious and go post credit or you you
introduce to james howlett and then you
can bring it for non-comic fans james
howard oh is of course logan wolverine
so making sure everyone else knows i
appreciate it james logan believe it or
not i actually did know that you've
earned the shirt so yeah in fact i'm
taking the goodwill tag off of it right
now that's how you earned the
taglessness by knowing james house i
don't regret the five dollars good
purchase
but that's i mean i think that's a
really cool new way because you
introduced him in the brian singer
movies as wolverine already established
already fully formed
logan so i don't necessarily love the of
the origin comics where he's got bone
claws and stuff that's not my cup of tea
you don't have to do that but this way
you could introduce project project text
that's a movie i yeah
we could do that in the mcu why not
found footage party movies let's do it
wolverine was a party guy in the 40s no
you introduce weapon x via the program
and then you've got a long game and that
way you could long form tie it back into
deadpool you can use the weapon age
program from deadpool because deadpool
is one of the only things we are
bringing back over all of this allows a
much richer world that you could
arguably have an entire wolverine
separate situation with sabertooth with
deadpool all those things and you could
have it rated r you could have the
daredevil login feature have the
wolverine show rated r and then when he
transfers over into the movies you don't
have to because you've established the
character rarity is i want a real
berserker rage i no absolutely i want to
be terrified just as much as i am
enamored with his coolness and that
takes a while that takes hours of screen
time in my opinion like that's the way
to do it better and you need an actor
then theoretically who like you know i
love hugh jackman and he definitely
brings the intensity but i'm not often
scared of him or i don't often have that
sort of monstrousness and i know that
wolverine in the comics is not quite as
uh charming let's say yeah so who are
some of your potential castings so he's
on the older end of the spectrum for the
casting because i'd want this man to
play him for 10 or 15 years
richard jenkins richard jenkins it's
richard says i mean it's time it's time
i think he's about to be in the mcu it's
time for richard tickets i would say uh
tom hardy to be honest i think you need
to find another tom hardy and i'm gonna
use tom hardy as the archetype because
he's short he's rough he definitely
seems like the guy that you don't want
to meet in a dark alley or he could
charm her pants off he's a guy that's
feral he's a guy that can do a lot
without dialogue mad max's tom hardy and
warriors tom hardy are wolverine like
the cage fighting element meets the guy
that doesn't say a lot throw a cigar in
there and that's wolverine so finding
someone like tom hardy or tom hardy
making a lot of art really quickly like
we're throwing a lot of shows out i'm
like there they could work i think he's
on the older side as far as playing him
that long i would love i know it's the
most commonly bandied about name but
taryn edgerton i do think has a very
good vibe for him i do think he's the
right stockiness i do think he's got the
charm as well as the animosity i do
think he can turn on that feral rage as
well as be a guy that could woo you know
jean grey and make people believe in him
because you need wolverine to be a guy
that's duplicitous in a way he needs to
be able to get in anywhere and then go
berserker so you need both sides of that
i'd also love to see an edgar ramirez i
think edgar ramirez is long overdue for
playing a superhero and i think he's got
right he's got an actual feral nest and
he's never really gotten the role that's
gotten to show that off but every time i
see him on something i'm like this guy's
right there like i see this this edge of
this interesting choice so those are my
big three um you know taryn being the
youngest tom hardy being the oldest
edgar ramirez isn't that much younger
than tom hardy but i think he's just
such an
interesting energy and like i could see
him being a guy that would jump off a
mountain and live in a cabin in canada
like that seems like edgar beerus
absolutely so you are not team radcliffe
you know what i love daniel radcliffe
but he always strikes me as a sweetie
yeah he's such a sweetheart and i mean
yeah i would love to to be surprised by
a monstrousness that i haven't seen
within him because he certainly does
have range but yes i also agree that he
does come with his sweetiness
as someone who's like interviewed tom
hardy been around tom hardy like you're
always wanting to make sure you're cool
with him and also a little intimidated
by him like tom hardy's just got a thing
where it's like you earn his respect
like tom hardy doesn't give you respect
you earn it and i think that's wolverine
you've got to earn his respect you've
got to earn him calling you bub like
he's got to be there so i think that's
really important to the character and i
don't think we've even gotten that
necessarily from hugh jackman because i
love you jackman but i feel like he's
just so nice and that sometimes
sometimes shines through and like he
does the feral well he does the
animosity well he does the as close to
pg-13 berserker as we can get but at the
end of the day i want someone that's a
little disconcerting yeah absolutely no
i would agree with that and i feel like
after such a well-worn portrayal that
does have so much charm and so many
iconic moments that people love i think
it would be good to re-establish the
energy of the character and the
association that we have with him and
maybe not use him in quite the same way
for the audience you know if we retread
the phoenix saga one more time
i like that that's the thing
we'll get it one of these days dude
we'll get it one of them
trilogy i want that to be the ninth
movie because you're 20 years down the
line at least yeah but like i think
that's why you really need to establish
a show and movies and i would also love
to see a show with cyclops and storm and
certain key x-men but starting with
wolverine that way you got the fans
happy and you get that cool combine
moments that leads me to one more
question before we get to recommendation
which is you know you mentioned you
definitely would would make wolverine a
show you might can entertain x-men as
either you know show movies both perhaps
even and he also mentioned not maybe
even time travel but just you know sort
of a time element for the wolverine show
that could maybe exist outside of those
movies like do you imagine wolverine
being a character where on the show we
follow him throughout these decades but
maybe in movies once they do collide and
that you know crossover event does
happen and we finally get the catharsis
of seeing wolverine amongst the x-men
yeah you know do you see that those
things existing sort of in the same
universe but peering in on different
moments in time absolutely i'd say the
x-men are more modern i'd keep wolverine
winnie's with the x-men modern but that
also allows you to do the characters
we've been wanting to see done right for
years on the show and not have them
necessarily tie into the x-men
sabertooth doesn't need to tie into the
x-men but i would do season one weapon x
program maybe saber-tooth introduced and
then cliffhanger saber-tooth for season
two season two lead into world war one
or world war ii and have wolverine in
the war for season three and then season
four as we're approaching modern day
cold war omega red i love the mcu like
we there's so little of it and i was
very spoiled by captain carter
especially and parts of agents of shield
the final season like going back into
like i love there's so much opportunity
in past eras so you're speaking my
language here and so uh why don't we
move on then to uh some recommendations
so i would say the best place to read
especially wolverine in a period of time
is frank miller's four issue mini-series
frank miller's wolverine is what i would
base the foundation of this on i think
it's really insightful it's really
introspective it's a lot about being a
warrior being a samurai and it does
allow you to see what wolverine's like
on his own which is very important there
are literally 300 plus solo wolverine
issues you could read just wolverine
without tying the x-men and tell decades
of stories but i would start with frank
miller's wolverine mini which is the
first of them which starts this 300
issue run i also really recommend
wolverine enemy of the state which is
illustrated by john meter jr and it's
basically a wolverine that has been
turned into a weapon because he's been
brainwashed and he's attacking and
massacring all of his friends he's an
enemy of the state because he's a
berserker that's being controlled by
someone else how do you take out the man
who can repair himself and how
basically he controls his friends and
that's the run that actually later
inspired a lot of the old man logan old
man things because wolverine in that
storyline was brainwashed by mysterio
and killed all of his friends starting
the old man universe which is very
popular to this day which also is kind
of what hugh jackman's logan was based
off of so i definitely recommend the old
man logan stuff but i'd read the one
that no one read as big first which is
enemy of the state and then my final
recommendation trying to stick to three
because i could literally do 20 but i'm
trying to do three per video we're new
to this this show but i'm gonna try to
stick to three i'd also recommend it's a
deadpool comic but it's a five issue
mini series called the good the bad and
the ugly and it's deadpool wolverine and
captain america
basically in korea freeing mutants that
have been mutated to be more like the
x-men they're trying to build a korean
team of x-men and they've enslaved
people and mutated them to be like
wolverine's storm deadpool they've
they've used deadpool's dna to mutate
these mutants and they're trapped in a
basically a camp you've got the trauma
of captain america seeing camps you've
got wolverine seeing what regeneration
factors do you've got deadpool actually
showing some heart and some ethos and
you see wolverine in a team dynamic that
isn't the x-men that's also what i think
could be really cool is that'd be how
i'd bring steve rogers back i wouldn't
touch captain america in the movies have
chris evans in world war ii teaming up
with wolverine as his big comeback cameo
don't mess with the continuity and then
you can even play with the red skull
stuff
wowie so that dude man i am dazzled in
this moment
and i'm sure the kids out there are
going to love catching up with some of
these stories that sound very family
appropriate not that that's three movies
all r-rated comic books effectively
they're like t-plus but yeah the good
the bad and the ugly uh wolverine's
frank miller mini-series enemy of the
state and then if you want a little
bonus old man logan very essential
reading and if you want more recs leave
a comment below if you want another
video just wolverine rex i can do that
for an hour awesome well dude thank you
for coming to my ted talk and for
helping me give all this information to
everybody you've been a big support to
me and all the work i did today thanks
for hosting comments yeah i know i
appreciate it it's a privilege and an
honor to be able to do that for you for
me and everyone else but uh guys thank
you for joining us i really appreciate
you all watching remember to subscribe
and hit that notification bell because
we're going to be having more theories
more koi and more awesome
recommendations so keep an eye out for
that and we'll catch you all soon
[Music]